ça lui fait sur mon lit là bon bref j'ai
eu l'occasion encore dernièrement de
croisé pas mal d'entre vous et il trouve
que définitivement la question qui
revient le plus souvent c'est comment va
cyril bon c'est vrai que ça fait
longtemps que je n'ai pas donné de ses
nouvelles
et comme il se trouve que aujourd'hui
c'est pile le jour de ma troisième
séance de laser je me suis dit que
c'était l'occasion
alors on y va
[Musique]
bon alors avant de commencer avant même
d'aller à la séance parce que je vous
propose c'est de faire un petit point
parce qu'il s'est passé deux mois depuis
la dernière fois alors j'ai l'impression
que ça commence gentiment à bouger mais
disons que c'est pas encore ça
regardez alors ça c'est cyril avant la
toute première séance de laser en sortie
de chez le tatoueur ça c'est lui après
la première séance
ça c'est lui après la deuxième séance
et ça c'est cyril ce matin juste avant
de partir
ouais bon alors disons que ça c'est
peut-être un petit peu éclairci mais
vraiment j'attends mieux et j'espère que
ça va être un petit peu plus
spectaculaires dans les jours qui
viennent
ah oui alors petite particularité la
dernière fois j'avais testé le
détatouage un lendemain de fête petite
précision hier soir je fais la fête
c'est un peu abuser des bonnes choses
pas se mentir c'est complètement con ne
fait pas ça là ce coup là je me suis dit
tiens on va tester le laser en pleine
canicule un comme ça vous aurez un
panorama des situations bien extrême
voilà donc là il est 7 heures qui fait
déjà bien chaud non c'est supportable en
a pas se mentir j'ai pas beaucoup dormi
à cause de la chaleur pendant que ça
peut voir sur mon faciès un petit peu
défraîchi et je me lève aussitôt c'est
parce que avant d'aller à la séance de
laser
je vais tourner une petite vidéo avec
des potes
petit tour à l'entrepôt est à saint
thois alors la séance
voilà la vidéo finish pour passer chez
moi quand même pour manger un petit
morceau et faire un petit brin de
toilette un parce que bon on n'est pas
des sahwa et là on y va alors il fait
moins chaud que ces derniers jours mais
il fait quand même bien chaud
non
[Applaudissements]
j'ai eu chaud
ok dans ce collège a vraiment pris un
vrai qu'il fait de la blessure mais
et au calme souffler un petit peu je
vous reparle de tout ça oui donc bon eh
bien cette fois le médecin a encore
augmenté la puissance c'est-à-dire
encore plus que la deuxième séance où il
avait déjà augmenté la puissance par
rapport à la première
autant vous dire que ça bien bien bien
fait mal même si j'ai essayé de rester
digne
[Musique]
d'ailleurs je sais pas pourquoi on fait
ça pourquoi on dit pas qu'on a mal quand
on a mal comprends pas bref donc entre
la chaleur et la douleur je peux vous
dire que j'étais vraiment vraiment
surchauffe un genre méga en sueur et où
j'ai pas fait de malaise mais j'étais
pas fier quand même donc il m'a dit
qu'elle était à la puissance maximale
pour ce diamètre de lasers et que la
prochaine fois on changerait de diamètre
de laser du coup quand vous dire que
j'ai hâte est donc le résultat c'est ce
que vous voulez bien sûr qu'on va là
c'est ce matin là c'est lendemain on
notera l'apparition de jolies petites
cloques et là c'est le jour d'après bon
ça va un peu mieux mais on sent que la
chair a été meurtrier le médecin est
confiant on va dire que moi aussi c'est
bon on n'avait qu'à la troisième séance
il en reste encore trois en à mi chemin
gardons la foi
maintenant ce que je vais faire c'est
que je vais laisser passer l'été par le
temps pour tous les petits macrophages
de bouffer les particules d'encre
explosé par laser et on verra à la
rentrée
et du coup à partir d'aujourd'hui et
pour deux mois on va se retrouver non
pas toutes les semaines comme d'habitude
mais toutes les deux semaines pour des
vidéos spéciale était alors vous savez
comme une commune et dernière en fait
alors bien évidemment d'ici là art pitié
je vous en supplie mettez vous bien et
surtout portez vous bien bel été
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]